it's Thursday and I'm about to punch you
in the mouth okay let's talk about
bullying now many of you have seen this
viral video over the last week nice
now most people actually did side with
the fat kid
sorry big boned but there are a few
people who think that violent
retaliation of any kind is wrong most
notably to school who still suspended
the fat kid sorry husky for four days
for having defended himself really see
that's the problem with these
zero-tolerance policies from schools
they're unrealistic as an adult if that
event had occurred outside of a bar or
restaurant any judge in the world would
watch the tape
oh mr. Crowder you're free to go you sir
you're in jail for aggravated assault oh
I'm worried that this might normalize
sanitized and glamorize hitting back or
violence as a response to being bullied
you mean that some children might deem
it acceptable to defend themselves from
violent bullies does that not seem
entirely appropriate let me know below I
think it's better if the bully learned
his lesson now as opposed to later on in
life when somebody snaps as an adult it
gets uglier
[Music]
[Laughter]
listen jerk when I tell you to come you
better come what you gonna cry for me
now cry see both of these children
learned a valuable lesson that they
could never been taught by teachers or
principal and ten years down the line
they will look back upon this event as
the key turning point in their young
lives see the fat kid sorry of good
stock learned that he doesn't have to
allow others to dictate his self-esteem
for the first time in years his chubby
middle life is actually his own and the
bully actually learned that he shouldn't
treat people like crap if only for
personal safety reasons also the
concrete hurts he literally had some
sense knocked into him oh but don't you
feel a little bad for the bully he's
just a kid I feel zero bad for him and
you know what happens when bullies
aren't steps down early in their
childhood qaddafi the bottom line is
this this bullying incident is a perfect
example of peace through strength for
every hundred people who believe in
non-violence there is one schmuck who
will always choose brutality simply
because he can and because he is willing
and if the good people are not just as
willing he wins that's how life works
and folks the beauty of dealing
violently with bullies is that it
usually only takes once after that it's
smooth sailing
[Music]
[Music]